[Musique]
air max même cet impressionnant survêt
de l'or surtout d'écoliers vision
recalant percée vers les centres et le
frère avant qu'ils perdent cnrc ambiance
tu connais déjà les deux bras croisés tu
connais le pas ce soir on sait les
menace assez mais n'a pas parlé en
français devant subliminal on a réglé
noël avant de les réaliser apprend à
nous connaître avant de nous pénaliser
frérot tamis les crocos sans les se sert
de ce combo c'est une mauvaise idée plus
froides senti les chaînes s'abritant
pierre blazy que nous consentons coupant
sans fil très bons sont même les tontons
danse sortions comme le seul son petit
bout
ce soir aussi parce que au final on est
au sol au delà de nous ce soir
parce que au final
[Musique]
official dons qu'ils imitent bon son
match on n'a rien rien de fictif on veut
le dicton qui fuit pas les victimes
ambiant scandale ce soir ça va faire des
victimes y en a marre aujourd'hui je
suis dedans je veux comines et je fais
le petit pas de danse j'étais dehors et
maintenant je suis dedans cheveux
gominés je fais le petit pas de danse
comme dans tout sport tous les coups
sont permis on est des classes et des
gains de verges et aucun verre vide qui
connaît le verdict ce soir en full
alternent avec les sons jazz ou quand
j'arrive savall est évident je suis
malade dans le bolide allemand c'est
nous les gentils et les méchants g10 et
où les gentils des méchants coups
ce soir en si mineur parce qu'au final
on est ok de là
nice ce soir
on est
et
et tous les soirs on fait la paix
exemple la porte
et
ce
[Musique]
de nos limites ce sens
parce que au final on est haut
[Musique]
de nos limites ce soir
parce que continent
les auditeurs